i get eight hours of sleep i prioritize
it unless i'm traveling in different
time zones sometimes it's impossible
i like things quiet i shut the door
actually at the office because i
i don't want to hear anybody talking
outside the way you have meaning in your
life
is you discover your gift wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today just live your
best believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one get enough
sleep with jeff bezos and so then on
sleep
i get eight hours of sleep i prioritize
it unless i'm traveling in different
time zones sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and
and for me i need adults to sleep i
think better
i have more energy my mood is better all
these things
and think about it as a senior executive
what do you really get
paid to do as a senior executive you get
paid to make a small
number of high quality decisions
your your job is not to make thousands
of decisions every day
so let's say that i slept six hours a
day or let's go really crazy and say i
slept four hours a day
so now i just got four so called
productive hours back
so if i was going to you know
have say 12 hours of productive time
during
any waking day now all of a sudden i
have 12 plus 4 i have
16 productive hours so i have 33
percent more time to make decisions so
if i was going to make
you know 100 decisions now i can make
133 decisions
if i did that arithmetic wrong i'm sorry
and and so you make 133 decisions
is that really worth it if the quality
of those decisions might be lower
because you're tired or grouchy or any
number of things
now it's different if it's a startup
company i mean you know you're really
you know when amazon was 100 people
that's a different story but
but amazon's not a startup company and
all of our senior executives
operate the same way i do they they work
in the future they live in the future
none of the people who report to me
should really be focused on the current
quarter
um i always tell people sometimes i get
you know we'll have a good
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working
on a quarter that's going to reveal
itself in 2021
sometime and that's what you need to be
doing you need to be out
sort of you know two or three years in
advance and
if you are and then why do i need to
make 100 decisions today if i make like
three good decisions a day
that's enough and they should just be as
high quality as i can make them
warren buffett says he's good if he
makes three good decisions a year
habit number two have meaning in your
life with charles
koch charles i love what i do as a
leader
and a journalist at exio's my dream
would be to do what i do at 65
75 yeah let alone 85.
how do you do that how did you make that
possible like what is your
regimen well the first thing as
as one of my another one beside
frederick douglass and my heroes victor
frankel
put it ever more people have the means
to live but more meaning for live for
the way you do it is have meaning in
your life and the way you have meaning
in your life
is you discover your gift
you and you follow maslow
what you can be you must be and whatever
your nature calls you to be
you dedicate yourself to that so i've
dedicated my
my myself to that to to learning every
day
trying to find new principles every day
searching for every how to better apply
the principles we we are applying them
and
every day try to improve so i wake up
every morning
what time i get up uh
use it a little before six say 5 45
get try to get to the office by seven
and
and and what keeps me going
is oh i think i can contribute today
and then i work out every day so you
work mind and body
and you have something to look forward
to every day
that this is the the problem people who
who just have stuff and don't do that
retired and just fool around i mean
i wouldn't last a year i'd be i'd been
dead long ago
this is the the where my alma mater
uh uh mit in latin it's
mind in hand
so body body and mind that's
and you work those every day which is
what i do
i know how you work your mind how do you
work your body
well i work out every every afternoon or
evening
and for about an hour and a half you've
got a gym here yeah i got a gym in the
basement
yeah i do i do cardio i do mat
core work and i do weights habit number
three
keep yourself updated with mark cuban i
usually get up
about 6 30 give or take first thing i do
when i'm laying in bed still
is i'll grab a phone and start going
through my email
whatever the the stressful things are i
try to get those out of the way in the
morning then i get myself
out of bed walk to our kitchen i'll have
some
decaf coffee and i'll eat my alicia's
healthy cookies
turn on one of the business news
networks and listen to what's happening
in the market
what's happening with tariffs all that
kind of stuff because it impacts a lot
of my companies
before i go to bed i put on a pair of
gym shorts
and a tank top and that's what i'm
wearing when i get up in the morning
until i shower and it's time to change
then i get really dressed up i put on a
pair of sweatpants
now if it's an important day i'll put on
a blue math shirt
if it's not as important today maybe
i'll put on like a
green matte colored t-shirt it really
just depends on who i'm seeing and how
important they are i got to take
my bright and shiny and smiling
15 year old daughter and drop her off at
school and this is going to sound really
weird but one day i'm online
and i'm looking through my mentions and
they're just blowing up and it turns out
it's a song
and the song is called mark cuban and
the way the song goes is
mark cuban always win never lose mark
cube and amir shark who are you
so being the dad that i am in the
mornings i gotta just
jam it out so i drive my kids crazy once
i drop her off monday wednesday or
friday i'm going to lifetime fitness and
i'm playing pickup i've been playing
pickup there forever
and i can't jump as high as i used to
but i'm money
do that come home take a shower um and
again
i'm working on emails habit number four
integrate with elon musk
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday
is it all tesla when you're up in
silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of as
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during
um interstitial periods like you're in a
car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake
and and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated
on my phone and then
and it's just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working
actually working so the way i generally
do it is i'll be
uh working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to the bay area
spent tuesday and wednesday at the bay
area
then at tesla and then flight back on
wednesday night
spent thursday and friday at spacex
in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
uh or spend saturday at tesla and sunday
at spacex
hi this is dan lok i want to share with
you a lesson from
evancar michael's new book build to
serve
this section is about making money from
your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that is significant
one that can pay you so you can quit
your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
build a lot or or build to sell or even
build a scale
it is built to serve and this book will
teach you
exactly how to do that habit number five
take time to read with warren buffett i
like things quiet
i shut the door actually at the office
because i i don't want to hear anybody
talking outside
his views and the belt-tightening
proposals and uh
i still probably spend five or six hours
a day reading look at what's trending
today our quick roundup of what has you
talking about what's amazing is the
stuff he remembers
[Applause]
it's like a little computer you know i
keep thinking the hard drive will run
out of space but it doesn't
he's one of the smartest people we know
habit number six keep
fit with richard branson the other
advantage of working
in from home is you know i and
especially living on an island is
keeping fit is very important um and you
know
every morning i get up and i play tennis
i make sure it's singles so with and
play with somebody better than me at pro
do the same in the evening um and we
have you know
um real battles um if the wind's up i'll
kite surf in the day as well
um and then you know between all that
you know work hard so
you know because i'm keeping healthy and
fit i actually get
i think more hours work in a day than
most people
habit number seven develop daily
disciplines with dan lok
for my emotional well-being 30 minutes
every day
in the morning i have my morning rituals
which includes my
visualization exercise includes my
attitude of gratitude exercise which if
you go to youtube you type in
attitude gratitude you type in dan lok
you see the recording that i listen to
every morning
with my own voice voiceover walk off
with a piece of music
i do that every day i do my breathing
exercise because i want to get
oxygen into my blood in the morning
fresh my day get it get it going so
that's my morning rituals 30 minutes a
day that's my daily discipline
non-negotiable you with me so far for my
emotional well-being yes
okay now for my financial well-being 30
minutes a day are looking at
financials investments reviewing of
numbers
i'm looking at those numbers check your
bank account every damn day
is it is it going up or is it going down
right financial well-being 30 minutes a
day looking at financials investment
reviewing of numbers
this is well-being 60 minutes how long
an
hour a day on marketing or
self-promotions
that includes youtube facebook instagram
interviews
everything one hour a day to market
my own brand so it could be you know
what this morning just this morning i
had an interview
uh with a podcast that's an hour so
that's my hour of the day
i did that interview i post on instagram
takes me five minutes
that's one thing post on facebook five
minutes bam that's done
right upload youtube video all these
things one hour every day
non-negotiable because if i'm not
pushing my brand i'm not marketing
myself
i'm not tuning my own horn right nobody
will toot your horn
you better be out there getting
attention the marketplace
i want to do that every day every day
every day and then growth so for growth
i have
60 minutes a day minimum learning they
would include reading or sometimes
listening to a program they say on my
way here i'm listening to an audio
program it takes me about an hour to get
here i got my day i got that in
right bam that's done so minimum one
hour day
learning and for my physical sorry
physical well-being
go 60 minutes a day so currently i'm at
like three times a week but i want to
get to a point where
i can do almost every day or at least
six times a day
one hour of exercise that's what i'm
aiming for what i'm working towards
so far i'm doing three times a day
that's like three times a week
okay i want to get to six seven times
and then also my goal another goal that
i have is to minimize my email
management to 60 minutes a day
currently it's probably at 80 90 minutes
per day just because the sheer
amount of emails that i get i want to my
goal is to cut it down to 60 minutes per
day
now as all my inner circle members
you know when they send me email my
reply is very very short
it is very very short how short
number how short is the email
yeah because guess what if you get the
amount of emails i get
you spend five minutes crafting an email
you get 200 emails
do the numbers does not work
i need to get my email done in seconds
if it's something that they feedback
they need feedback on
another thing i do i will make a video
so i use a program called jane j
i ng from uh from i think uh
yeah tech tech software for text yeah
text or something like that but jing is
what i use this is free
and i could make a quick video it's not
typing long email it's like
it captures your screen capture i walk
them through different things plus it's
recording my voice
i upload the link i send them a link
they can watch that saves me a whole lot
of time
again it's a time-saving tool but also
clarity because sometimes
oh dan can you reveal this website for
me if i
take a look and i type it out guess what
a lot of miscommunication
and then the uh what about this and then
i've spent more time
explaining it back and forth back and
forth versus making a video they get it
usually very little back and forth so
that's another tool that i use
okay so that's my daily disciplines
whatever your daily disciplines
or you better have some you better have
some
if you don't schedule it it won't get
done so i schedule my lunch time
i schedule my lunch time i schedule my
email time uh my mom again makes me an
appointment with me sunday 9 00 p.m to
11 p.m
long distance call my wife makes a point
with me leisure time vacation time
husband time now i've already just give
you an example block out about
67 days for 2017.
67 days that includes veg dlic
mastermind meeting speaking gigs
masterminds vacations
that's how you script it out that's what
i mean
you don't just oh well you know what
i'll take the vacation whenever
we will do it i'll do that whenever no
don't do that don't do that now i've got
a very special bonus clip that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you i don't
think my personality has changed much
since i was five years old
uh i think as i explained to the kids
just a little while ago
uh probably the single most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success
has been my uh my questioning of
conventional wisdom
my doubting of experts just because
they're experts
and questioning of authority and while
that can be
very very painful in terms of your
relationship with your parents and your
relationship with your teachers
it's enormously useful in life i was uh
adopted with my own within my own family
when i was nine months old i was
i was born in new york city uh my mother
was 19 she wasn't married
and really was unable to care for me i
tried tried until i was nine months
old and then i was adopted by my
maternal aunt and uncle in chicago and
moved to chicago at the south side of
chicago
and i'll never never never again
complain about a bad neighborhood moving
from the lower east side of manhattan to
a still worth worse neighborhood on the
south side of chicago so
after after my ninth month i kept my
mouth shut about the neighborhood
i believed until i was 12 years old that
uh that i was not adopted i had no idea
that i was adopted
with within my own family uh so
again i don't attribute very much of
my life my personality to my adoption i
i do
attribute it an awful lot to my
relationship with my father
uh who was a russian immigrant
came uh came here was very very poor
dearly loved this country as only an
immigrant can
loved our government as only an
immigrant can he was a
he was a pilot in world war
ii uh bomber pilot he um
he really had the philosophy of my
country right or wrong he never
questioned
the government's policies never
questioned authority and didn't really
want me to question authority uh
i had some teachers when i was very very
young that i that i thought
were telling me things that weren't true
and when i tried to ask questions
they basically wanted me to respond
basically you know parent back what they
said they really weren't interested in a
discourse with a child
or a debate with a child they said this
was true and you are smart if you can
repeat
back to me exactly what i said to you
and i had a real problem with that as
well so i had very strong
authoritarian figures both in school
and at home which served as wonderful
examples of how not to be
my mom was supportive and i had a
mixture of teachers some of the teachers
were wonderful and some of the teachers
were awful
but the awful teacher the awful teachers
served a good purpose
in terms of being about me a bad exam
all examples are good bad examples
are useful good examples are useful and
uh it taught me to question experts
uh to question authorities uh figures
don't assume just because they're an
authority
or even just because they're an expert
that they're right in other words think
things out for yourself come to your own
judgments
don't simply conform
uh to conventional ways of thinking
conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this uh a lot of things
are are based on fashion even morality
at times is based on fashion
it was once found you know slavery was
once not considered not to be immoral
uh you know people are you know people
are shocked that
the uh the ancient greeks had slaves
that
that we had slavery in this country as
recently as you know 130 140 years ago
so there are more moral thoughts you
have to really go back to first
principles and think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out for yourself
if you want to know seven other rich
people habits that you need to try
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
this is something that people tend to
avoid because it's
it's painful yeah but but
i think this is a very common mistake is
to to not actively seek out